can a girl just be minimal and still use
thousand devices at once
[Music]
happy friday everybody oh
man i feel like i'm racking up like
sleep debt right now
because i went to bed at midnight and
we'll go by seven
hi ellie which is a little less sleep
than i
feel like my body should get because my
eyes are really like
tired but good thing about sleep debt is
that you can always sleep and get that
sleep back
ellie you've gone so big you want to
tell
how many pounds you weigh to people now
it's a lot of pounds when did you get so
big
when did you use your big elbow anyway
uh ellie and i wanted to take a moment
to thank the sponsor of today's video
helix right ellie you want to thank
helix for the bed that you sleep on
every night even though we got you a dog
bed too
you're part of the last ad for helix too
do you remember that
really all i want to be doing is napping
on this mattress right now
but i gotta turn on my stream later and
do some work before the weekend but i
wanted to tell you about the helix
mattress because ellie and i
enjoy it a lot so everybody sleeps
different and helix knows that because
we're all different people with
different bodies and different sleep
patterns and methods and stuff
so helix actually made a sleep quiz to
match you to the best mattress based on
your sleep preferences
i'm typically like a back and side
sleeper
really depends just like on the season
or something
and then scott's also the same we both
enjoy kind of like a medium
firm to firm mattress so we also took
the quiz on
helix sleep and we got matched with the
dusk lux mattress in cow king
it's pretty easy to set up because once
you buy it online it gets shipped right
to your door
you unroll it and you set it up on your
mattress and then
all of a sudden you're getting like much
better sleep than you were before
because you're mashed
with a mattress that works for your body
choosing a mattress is kind of a big
decision because you're going to sleep
on it every night and depending on the
quality of the sleep that you get
then it's kind of going to set the tone
for the rest of your day and so if it
makes you nervous that you're buying
something that you haven't even tried
it's okay because helix sleep has a 100
night sleep trial
so even after three months and you still
don't like the mattress then
they'll pick it up for you and you'll
get the full refund so make sure to
visit the link below in the description
box or go to helixleep.com for
up to 200 off your very own mattress
with two free pillows
thank you again helix for sponsoring i
think ellie's ready for her nap she's
in full napping position now
wow that's awkward that you can see my
backside hello everybody
happy monday i haven't vlogged in a
while because
i always get stuck into this vlogging
rat where i'm like i don't want to pick
up my camera because i don't know what i
would vlog about
i find myself in moments where i'm like
i should have vlogged that
so this week i'm just going to try to
have my camera
monday most of the time and hopefully
that'll work
it's actually extremely windy here in
san diego today
we have a high wind and surf advisory
for like
winds that are supposed to be like 30 to
60 miles per hour
so it's been kind of crazy the wind's
been really howling
in other news
this got so loud in other news
y'all know that i stream on twitch
monday through friday's co-working
sessions
what you don't know is that i've
actually been using scott's
stuff for like the last year literally
i've been streaming for a year and i've
been using scott's stuff the whole time
so i finally got my own gear
because i was like you know i think this
twitch thing
is gonna stick so i bought all this new
stuff
which i'm excited to set up i got the
rode psa1 studio
arm got a cable
the logitech brio which i'm actually
currently using
i like using it it's a very good high
quality camera the uh
autofocus is not great on it just like
how the autofocus on this camera is not
great right now
but i was like why ruin a good thing and
just
keep going with that here's my sound
mixer
the presonus studio 24c i actually have
a beefier one right now this one's
gonna go to scott because it's a little
too beefy and so this one only has
two inputs uh and i think it should suit
my needs and it'll help me simplify
everything
and then i got the streamer mic
the short sm7b the legendary
vocal microphone because you ain't a
streamer i guess if you don't have this
which is not true you can use whatever
microphone you want as long as it works
fine
finally got all of my stuff and i should
set it up it's just
you see this chord management that i
have to deal with
i just chord managed it like two weeks
ago and i have to redo all of it
so i'm not really looking forward to it
ellie would you like to manage my chords
for me
would you like to manage my chords for
me please can you do the chord
management
mama will teach you how to do chord
[Music]
it's the evening of the next day
and we're finally doing it scott's
helping me put together
my desk uh and put all my stream stuff
i actually took my mic out for a spin
today for today's train and it worked
great but i always have this issue where
i have too
many gadgets and not enough space or
smart
storage like can a girl just be
minimal and clean uh and still
use like a thousand devices at once
because
i would like that it ain't that easy
also every single electronics ever is
black
i mean i have some black on my desk but
like i've got this cute
whitish woodish kind of vibe
going be nice if they made things a
little cuter
and still high quality you feel is this
sexism
is that why i'm covering something about
the electronics industry in that a lot
of it is still very male oriented
um interesting scott what are you doing
saying my room setting up your room yeah
oh so you're not gonna help me put my
room together no you're
gonna just put your room together yeah
all right well
i guess i guess i guess we do this thing
you need me for
i don't know i thought you were gonna
help me i mean once you get to the part
where
you need my help but you're setting up
your own you're just like setting up
your stuff right now yeah
division of labor is hard project
management's hard
right scott no
it's fine i'll just do it myself i can
do it myself i know how
this [ __ ] works i'm an engineer right
scott
zero face
[Music]
cord management's hard i've gotten to a
point where i don't even know what i
want my desk to look like
like it's just my desk is super wide
and i want like certain things to be in
certain corners like i want my mic
there i want my webcam there my pc is
there
and then i also kind of want my laptop
to be in this general area too this is
hard this is like
a problem it's like a puzzle in and of
itself
how do i make an elegant solution with
what i
have because part of me is like this
would all
be good if i just buy new
but i don't really want to in reality if
i'm gonna buy anything it's probably new
wires that are long enough
it is now eleven o'clock and
i think i've done what i can and
it basically looks exactly like how it
did before except
i have a new mic but it looks pretty
soon
but i mean all the cords are clean up so
maybe maybe i'm done
i just i just don't know how people make
these like beautiful looking desktops
it just escapes me like what i really
care about is just an open
table top and that's all i want maybe i
should just wipe
clean and just like get all new stuff
ugh
so hard but i think i'm done so i'm just
gonna put everything back now
[Music]
happy wednesday afternoon fam
so today the 27th is actually scott's
birthday
usually we don't even go out to eat and
stuff we usually just like cook
food at home so tonight on the menu
we're going to do korean fried chicken
and then homemade cheesecake and i
thought this could be a good opportunity
to try making a basque cheesecake
which as far as i can tell is like a
browned
kind of burnt cheesecake i think the
really legit one is actually like pretty
burnt
um but it's supposed to taste really
good so this one doesn't look
that burnt i'm using the recipe from bon
appetit but i think it'll be good
you know i wanted to try a different
kind of cheesecake this time so
let's try what do i need for the
[Music]
cheesecake
i just realized you don't have sugar so
i'm gonna go get sugar
i'm back
[Music]
okay i cooked for a solid straight uh
two hours
happy birthday scotty
i figured we'd make it kind of festive
in here right
here's what's on the menu basically this
dinner is sponsored by maangchi your
favorite we got
corn cheese we got korean fried chicken
chopped jay salad because we're old
and this is the basque cheesecake
happy birthday
[Music]
all right happy sunday we're out
and about to get out
of our house to go meet jossie for the
first time in real life
because him and his wife are in town so
this is a moment in which an internet
friend becomes an irl
friend and i was telling scott we
haven't met anyone in person in so long
and i feel out of practice that i'm
nervous about it
[Music]
oh
happy monday slash february everybody
so i got stuff for a couch
i uh this space over here is actually
very empty
um it used to have a couch and then
it was too small i wanted it to be the
full width of this room
so i decided to move that one out and i
bought a new one from ikea which means
that i have to assemble it
so i'm going to do that but
[Music]
us
um
[Music]
do
all right so it's done it's kind of
weird because i feel like
the cushion covers are bigger than the
cushion themselves
like they just look kind of big right
they look kind of pom-pon
and it's definitely a little bit wrinkly
even though
i ironed it but that's just how it's
going to be so
i'm pretty happy with this i like how
low it sits and i like how i can lean
back
i am going to have to put a blanket on
it though because the dogs are going to
be all over this thing
and i don't know how long the white is
gonna last and i only got the white
because it was like the only color that
i could
order online and get delivered but there
are companies
where i can buy like the cover for this
thing
so at some point i will do that once
this gets too dirty i think
i'm excited to have this room a little
bit more filled out if i'm honest with
you
oh good girl what do you think
oh boy you approve of it i think
ellie what do you think like it
that blanket is there for you because
you always have muddy paws
happy tuesday lunch time so
mcdonald's has this pokemon happy meal
so that's what we're having for lunch
today it's so cute i don't know which
one's which
i don't know which one's itch either i
haven't had a happy meal since probably
i was a kid
apparently they all come with a pokemon
card because right now scott has a
little pokemon card obsession
after jarvis came over for the holidays
so much so that he did a stream last
week where he opened a bunch of his
childhood pokemon cards
that it's in there maybe do you want to
open that first before you eat it let me
eat this
there's no like hollows or anything
right it is one hollow really
i'll open it later oh my goodness
i feel like i should get a happy meal
every time
it's cheaper just to get the dollar menu
is it though because this comes with
fries
and a thing and a drink and it's like
three bucks
and it comes with this boy and it comes
with a toy exclusive mcdonald's
fries is one of the best ones really
i like burger king fries too though but
like the burgers are priced specifically
at the ucsd
price center burger king i remember
those
those fries were really good but i don't
know if it was because their fries are
really good or because
every time i ate them i was so hungry
and i was just a hungry college kid
that needed a study snack how cute
these are like paper packs they are
paper packs could we actually get them
sent in to be graded
ooh charmander holo
charmander snivy snivy
pumpkin
yeah it's the other three starters oh
it's a hollow turret wig
i feel like the hollow charmander is
pretty good it's pretty cool yeah
these are the two hollows we got yeah
well that was fun
now we're gonna go get him some more are
we gonna go eat something
this was scott's pokemon corner
you